are you sick of destiny yet yes well
tough I don't make the news man you shut
cam it looks like a player has wandered
into an unfinished area of Bungie shared
world shooter I'm Lucy and come with me
now and this TS news update as we head
into the terminus so yes one curious
destiny player has managed to find a way
to enter an unfinished part of the game
world that will not officially open
until an update which is currently
scheduled for release in 2015 a location
called the terminus was recently cited
as a future DLC level after summer
Bundy's plans for future content leaked
online in order to reach the terminus
players will need to stand inside a
large vertical beam that funnels them up
to a location far up in the cloud but
the beam is not currently active
youtuber nowise 10 has managed to reach
the apex by meticulously triple jumping
onto various wall appendages and then
tightrope walking across the scaffolding
that surrounds the vast beam funnel if
anyone's going to triple jump into a job
in QA after all of this it's no wives 10
the video offers a guide into how to
reach the area which is on the planet
Venus it currently offers the reward of
picking up three dead ghosts the
terminus will officially unlock when the
house of wolves DLC is released which at
the minute they scheduled for some point
in 2015 so are you gonna try and hop
skip and jump your way to the terminus
let me know in the comments for the
latest on destiny including the iron
banner bounties make sure to keep your
eye on gamespot